so how was your day
[Music]
the turning I think it's called the
turning right so the turning is a movie
I actually forgot the name of when I
went to purchase my ticket I was like oh
that that scary movie that comes out
tomorrow with Finn Wolf's heart in it
whatever that is true story it happened
it stars Mackenzie Davis Mackenzie Davis
becomes a live-in nanny to these kids
it's a big creepy house no parents
though there's this really old maid lady
she bonds with the little girl played by
Brooklyn Prince because the little girl
is really nice she totally conflicts
with the older brother played by Finn
wolfhard because that older brother is a
dick which I'm sure he had a really fun
time playing he was like look I've been
nice guy Mike for years give me
something I want to be a douche in a
movie while he's auditioning and now we
have ourselves a scary haunting movie
kind of well this movie actually
frustrates me because there are things
in here that I like the concept of but
not the execution I feel like I say that
about a lot of scary movies these days
this movie actually treats itself like a
psychological thriller which first of
all I liked that it was going that route
there were a few times in this movie
where there's just there's imagery in
the background maybe you'll see a face
somewhere and you're just like but the
movie never breaks to focus in on it to
tell you like yeah you totally saw a
face in the background and it's not like
the characters were all pushed to one
side of the frame with this open chasm
where you know something's gonna happen
like oh we're just kind of pushed to the
side look at all that space over there I
wonder if something's gonna happen right
there who saw that coming exactly it
wasn't like that there was an element of
nuance it felt kind of clever for a bit
for a bit and then the pacing yeah I
wasn't wearing a watch but at a point in
this movie I really wished I was wearing
a watch because I wanted to check the
time luckily I wasn't wearing a watch
because I probably would have just been
demoralized because I imagine the movie
was only on for about 40 minutes at that
point out like two hours everyone in the
movie did a fine job I felt like they
did a good job for what they had and the
end of this movie I like the concept of
not gonna spoil it for you but I like
were they tried to go but again the
execution just didn't land rather than
this really compelling ending like this
is our sixth sense moment this endings
gonna bring people back to the movie
theater you just feel like
did you guys run out of film time or
budget you just had to wrap it right
there because that's what it feels like
from what I can remember nothing I'm
gonna watch the movie again but from
what I can remember the ending directly
conflicts or the implication of the
ending directly conflicts with the
beginning of the movie so what's the
point of the ending yeah they probably
ran out of budget you have this oh my
gosh what's the ending it's the end of
the movie as you know it's that also why
didn't she just leave before the
haunting ish things really started
amping up and it was just like a creepy
house maybe a couple of creepy things
happened and one of the kids was a
complete dick why not be like you know
what [ __ ] this is a summer job anyway
I'm gonna go home and do some shots with
my old college roommate bye pretty much
how we all left the theater kinda like
didn't she just lead usually in haunting
movies people don't leave to go home
because the haunted house is their home
she does struggle with that for a second
but she's like I I did pinky promise I'd
stay oh you're right you don't want it
they'll throw you into five-year-old
jail for that you don't want to break a
pinky promise there's a caveat there's a
clause to the pinky promise you can
break it if one of the kids is a dick
but the little girl might be in danger
because her brother's a dick all right
call CPS do that and a big thing is any
time there was something kind of clever
happening you know like oh did I or
didn't I see a face like I said before
the vessel carrying you through that
scenario was just kind of the same old
[ __ ] and the last act of this movie I
was like okay now the ghost is just
chasing them any cleverness this movie
had just now the ghost is chasing them
also it's a named ghost and I love the
fact they start throwing out the name
and I'm like who is that they're talking
like I'm supposed to know who the [ __ ]
that is who is that a lot of times when
that happens in a movie I always want to
blame myself first it's like maybe you
weren't paying attention Jeremy but
never this one I'm gonna go ahead and
say they could have done better I feel
like they've dropped the name earlier on
but it was like oh yeah name is that
goes Oh PB&J sandwiches my favorite
we're on the other ship yeah I was just
like stop talking about ghosts like it's
been a main character who died 3/4 of
the way through this film actually I
humor the idea that maybe that ending
where it's like you know cliche ghost is
chasing him they need to escape this is
actually what it feels like it's like
they did a test screening with a control
audience and the audience was like that
ending sucks I like fun we'll keep that
ending and then do a second ending okay
oh [ __ ] we ran out of budget
it's the end
folks in the end I'm not mad at this
movie I'm just disappointed cause it
actually showed promise it's like I like
the concept of this I like the concept
of that actually like the concept of the
end but it's all about execution and
pacing don't bore me along the way this
is one of those movies that actually is
deserving of a remake I feel like this
movie could get a remake and they could
bring something better to the table and
when that remake inevitably happens and
I watch it it'll feel like I'm watching
it for the first time because I'm not
gonna remember this one in t-minus one
day ya already forgot right so the
turning have you seen it why did you
think about it
what'd you think of the gentleman
actually real question scrap those other
ones what is a scary movie or horror
movie or any movie in particular I had
interesting concepts in it just wasn't
executed so well whatever it is whatever
you think comment below let me know and
as always if you like what you've seen
here and you want to see more click
right here to see more
[Music]